as a fan of the first season season two
you guys really amped it up a notch
especially with these guest stars I mean
first we had Robin and this season we
got Barney I mean what was it like to
have another OG member of How I Met Your
Mother on the set I mean I was really
nervous to work with NPA really he's
just such a stunts legendary
dude
the fact that he said yes made us really
excited and I think obviously our goal
is to hopefully collect them all yeah
yeah that would be the dream I mean I I
feel like it's a testament to how people
and especially people who worked on the
original show loved this like franchise
it's like what I think is so brilliant
about our show that it does really
organically is it creates a completely
new world for people who never saw the
original yeah like a new Dynamic we're
not trying to replicate the dynamic of
the original and yet there are still all
these Easter eggs sprinkled throughout
but I feel like also you guys have
recreated that Dynamic too I mean this
cast like the chemistry is so unreal
like do you still pinch yourself we're
lucky man yeah and this is to do with
the casting with each other how we are
as people everything it's like we all
Vibe so well right it's true to be able
to come and work with people that you
genuinely think of as friends as like
it's an easy way to show up at work the
writers are also like creating very fun
things for us yeah so we're kind of like
looking forward to that reading our
episodes each week and being like Oh my
God you have this crazy thing
[Music]
that episode with Meghan Trainor and the
shrimps and the home birth I mean that
do they have to
have to end the shrimp and did you have
to fall into the pool too like it's
hilarious though it's so good the shrimp
water I'll never forget you're like I'm
never gonna eat shrimp again
it was real
yes oh my God
it's real oh my God yes and it was fishy
shrimp water not fishing strip water
yeah and they love to pair me with
shrimp I don't know why so uh let's
let's just manifest a third season
already sure who else on the list of the
OG cast members would you love to come
and play with you guys I think Jason
Siegel just because in my head he's like
17 feet tall and I I just want that to
be proven true when I meet him I think
for me it would be Josh just because I
feel like the similarity to like the
characters not the characters but just
like if you have to light us all up like
that that makes like the most sense for
sure storytelling wise I see it uh you
know obviously every great sitcom has a
great love story or love Saga I should
say and of course there are two
characters it's that whole will they or
won't they you know so when will they is
what I want to know is it coming we
can't tell you that yeah you don't want
to know you don't want to know until you
see it her safety you're not bringing
that you're right it would totally just
get used against me I do think the
writers Isaac and Elizabeth the creators
of the show do a really brilliant job of
like teasing things out letting them get
close let them get further apart yeah it
is it is it goes like this yeah yeah
it's great and
just said we're just starting to like
feel good about it yeah love Adventures
without me that's easy yeah it's true I
do definitely don't worry I get a lot of
them some insane ones buddy yeah not for
nothing but John Corbett
what are we laughing at we're just
razzing our friend because she's dating
an old guy
I believe that's me
I know everybody's been talking about
this but you guys going from you know
teacher and student on one project to
now passing jobs you never know where
they're gonna take it and you embrace it
right we did we did yes we did now were
you huge Sex in the City fan yes of
course so what was your reaction she's
always Aiden even right yeah yeah even
when he was my teacher so the fact that
we have now learned that Aiden will be
showing up in the second season the
reboot what was your reaction did you
try to get any tea from John
um John
me tea he's just like he thinks
everything's great and everyone's great
and he like
you know he's just a really easy going
yeah he was like the mellowest person
you've ever met on set he never broke a
sweat the guy was just cool as a
cucumber start to finish there has been
some fan theories that you are actually
the father have you seen those I've seen
them yeah I love them
but all I'm gonna say is Ice Cream
Elizabeth man you never know what's
gonna happen boom boom boom Come Close
go far no speaking of not knowing what's
gonna happen that Cliffhanger can we
talk about that like how will a
long-distance marriage work for your
character
oh we'll have to see man long distance
are hard right have you got long
distance before you have okay so you're
bringing some truth to this oh storyline
always bring the truth but yeah it's
tough yeah but it's like real too right
we need those like we need that story
arc too to play out on a show like this
I was I was just thinking that you
just like I'm
like serious moments and it's just so
nice to have that with our comedy
there's so many relatable things like
how hard a long-distance relationship
absolutely truly is or growing pains
you're making like decisions you don't
want to make or like like our show does
have a lot of that and it's it's really
nice because play it out there is a lot
of goofy there is a lot of silly like
we're Pratt falling and like getting
things dumped on us and like it is very
funny and I think one of the things
that's nice about doing 20 this season
is it it gave the writers a lot of
Runway to find opportunities for some
sort of dramatic higher Stakes moments
without sacrificing like a boatload of
Comedy absolutely and crazy scenarios
for sure it gets me excited for a third
season because there's still so much
more that you could do in like places to
go yeah I feel like we're just getting
started I agree I agree too is
foundations yeah oh man but it's so good
into so much more I mean season one was
awesome but season two was like so much
better and crazier and funnier and more
just like off the walls
[Music]